pair of Democrats running for president
or getting a boost from the New York
Times editorial board for the first time
ever the paper endorsed two candidates
in the primaries Elizabeth Warren and
Amy Klobuchar The Times says that Warren
is the best leftist candidate while
Klobuchar is a centrist choice they and
their Senate colleagues are squeezing in
campaign appearances before the
impeachment trial ed O'Keefe is covering
campaign 2028 he joins us with more on
this story so and I have a couple things
how significant are these endorsements
especially since they've now endorsed
two candidates and that's never happened
before yeah well you know people in Iowa
New Hampshire very unlikely they care
what two New York Times editorial board
has to say especially if they can't even
pick one candidate there are still a
dozen in the race and the senators
Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren Amy
Klobuchar and Michael Bennett spent the
weekend with voters in New Hampshire and
Iowa admitting that they might not be
back to campaign much if the impeachment
trial runs several weeks and now there's
a new fight brewing between two
contenders Sanders is calling out former
Vice President Joe Biden's record on
Social Security
Sanders argues Biden's record shows an
openness to cutting benefits while
Sanders has long supported social
security protection Biden disagrees and
spent the weekend strongly criticizing
the Sanders campaign for in accurately
characterizing his record I have been a
gigantic supporter of Social Security
from the beginning and I have a detailed
plan as what the do for social security
to make sure that the good news is
people are living longer the bad news is
they're running out of the coverage
their Social Security can cover we're
not going to make personal attacks on
Joe Biden but I think the record shows
that Joe's history in the Senate and my
history in Congress are very different
Biden as a senator was open to cuts to
Social Security to help balance the
budget but is now calling to expand the
program today most of the candidates
will end up in Iowa and what organizers
call the brown and black forum an event
held every four years before the
caucuses to discuss issues of concern to
black and Latino voters who make up a
small but in closed elections like this
year important percentage of people in
the state Tony all right thank you very
much